you
[Music]
so we're starting with binding from
Michaels research he's going to talk
about improving OCC by construction
practice matching interviewing yeah you
don't know oh this is Optimus mr.
concurrent control but it's too crowded
I cannot put everything here okay hi
everyone I'm by loading from Microsoft
to research and today I'm going to talk
about improving OCC per transaction
batching an operation reordering this is
publishing the ODB this year so you can
look it up on life you want to know more
details about this work this is joint
work with your hand and general set and
now we get started ok before that we
also get into transactions I would like
to give an overview of what is going on
in my group so I work in the DMX group
and in Microsoft Research and the full
name is Darren management and
exploration exploration and mining group
so as the name indicates our group works
on a variety of different projects in
the space of data management and data
analytics so here is a just a sample of
what is going on here and this is a by
no means a completely complete list and
please feel free to talk to me or my
colleagues after the talk if your
interesting knowing more about those
projects ok so the first one is the self
storage state of information so idea is
probably similar to our previous speaker
is to democratize data preparation for
AI but we are also the market has a data
conversion for bi as well so how we have
an edge here the second project is
proximal query processing so as you know
like for some of the exploratory data
analytical tasks it makes much more
sense to first get a rough idea of like
back of envelope calculation of what is
going on in the data before you consume
all resources and spend a lot of time on
getting the exact answer so Sergio has
led an effort on how to do approximate
query processing on with a large amount
of data with some guarantees now the
next one is the actor or any database
systems this is this is our classic of
collaboration that I feel on how to end
database functionality on top of our
actor or entity framework so that you
can
do are some of the like scalp do sorry
can do some obscure bore for torrent and
me to your applications such as multiple
era games IOT and telemetry and mobile
devices and finally there is the
automatic physical design in the cloud
project where Sudipta and I and a bunch
of colleagues were trying to
automatically build physical illnesses
for the database in the cloud so as we
know the database indexing is a critical
for the performance of the database so
pyre work most of our work tried to
position the index recommendation as a
tool to facility some of the human
experts to selecting disease for a given
workout on a given database so in a
cloud service however ever you will be
way too expensive for humans to oversee
in the decisions of the Eunice's are
millions of data bases so in this work
or in this project we are proposing a
closed-loop solution to continuously and
automatically read to the queries and
workload to reduce the actual query
execution time instead of the estimated
cost of the queries in this way we are
trying to remove human intervention in
the critical path of the indexing or
query database tuning process so in
contract to some of the prior work we
are actually looking to the full
pipeline of the whole process including
not just index recommendation but also
the workflow extraction the index
recommendation validating and monitoring
of what happens after you implemented
those indices so in this case we measure
the success of the implementing index in
terms of the execution of the career
cost instead of the estimated cost
during this process one thing more or
less law as a side product we observed
is that during because we are
continuously tuning and monitoring and
changing the configuration of the
databases we can see or observe multiple
executions of different plans for the
same query so if based on those
execution data we can actually construct
new plans to improve the quality of the
plan at very low risk
to reduce the execution cost if we have
this kind of data so if we are
interesting more about those things
place to look at just top me talk to me
afterwards or look at the everything is
containing those papers okay now so much
about my group let's go the actual chess
actions okay so optimistic on currency
culture is a transaction concurrency
control protocol which where a
transaction first executes its
operations and optimistically assuming
there is no conflict in transaction
going on with it and before it commits
to the databases you store all the
updates in its pirate work for us
workspace now before commenting there is
actually some procedure to check or
validate whether there is actually no
transaction conflicting with this one so
if there is not it goes into the right
wrist where it tries to make its updates
available for others to see now if there
is conflict transaction with other
transactions you will just support so
here is the example of like one-hour
transaction in optimistic concurrency
control can abort
so for example we have two transactions
t1 and t2 where t1 read x and y and
modify X where T to read x and y X and Z
and modify Z so in the real face they
read the data item make the update in
their local workspace now after that the
interest of validations face where t1
tries to commit or tries to check if
there is any one complicating with it
for the updates it has to make so in
this case there is nobody conflict
remains t1 so you can commit and update
the value of x to 30 now here comes to 2
because the value of x has been updated
to 30 and t2 just read all developed and
assume we're running
answer all about transaction in this
case the t2 actually has a still read
and it has to abort in this case so this
is how our transaction can abort any
optimistic concurrency control because
we don't lock everything now
the question we ask here is that does T
to really have to abort now
it turns out in this example the t2 has
a steward so it's sort of a hopeless it
has to abort but if we can switch the
order of how t1 and t2 sterilized for
example instead of sterilized t2 t1
first which there are the two two first
in this case t2 can make it up there to
Z and then when we valued at t1 there's
also no conflict with t1 so t1 can also
make its up there to X so both of the
transaction can commit with a different
sterilization order now the question is
that can we also like people might be a
bit nervous that whatever can we really
also like manipulate the sterilization
order of the transactions actually in
OCC optimistic control the answer is yes
the reason is that in optimistic
concurrency control the serialization
order is depends on like how the order
concurrent transactions how they execute
and how they like when they come to the
validation phase so you know normal
operation of I also say the transactions
can come and whichever order they want
so basically there is the freedom of
which order the actual being sterilized
and the validator so as we see agent
famously with Olivia's supervision we
can actually construct a data order than
the order that they come to the system
so not only that we actually can extend
the idea of reorder the transactions to
reorder the operations of the
transaction not only in the validation
phase but also throughout the life of
the transaction and we can further try
to patch transactions to increase the
opportunity of reordering and also to
scope out how far we you are going to
look at when you do the reordering so
this is the batching action makes it
explicit and easier for us to do the
reordering work now here's the is a life
of a transaction a client first descent
a transaction to the system in our
corner
execute the transaction you should read
and write a request to the storage so
before the storage actually answer those
requests there is some matura that tries
to patch the operation to put the
operations into batches and to reorder
the read and write request now the store
to reply to the transaction coordinator
and after finish all the operations of
the transaction it is sent to the
validation phase so before it actually
get validated there is also component
which tries to patch the validation
request and tries to reorder the
transactions so that we can get a better
civilization order so from the
architecture we can see there are
multiple points the transactions are
matched and reordered
for example the action of the
transaction can be a batch even before
they enter the system for is a man the
client you get a bunch of transactions
you can decide in which order you usual
the transaction to reduce the conflict
on this is beyond the scope of this work
but there has been some prior work on
how to do this static analysis of
transactions to reorder them now here we
have focus on the reorder the operations
the retry request and the storage and
also reorder the transactions and the
valuation so in a storage is the
strategy the optimal strategy is
actually fairly simple because we want
to power it has all the rights before
all the reads from a batch of operations
so that for the real operations we don't
read any like a stale state which is
happen to be updated by someone else in
a batch but at the validation layer the
reordering strategy strategy is less
straightforward so essentially the
question we are asked is that how can we
create a sterilization order with the
least number of ports given batch of
transactions now formally the problem is
to like give up the actual transactions
the state B we want to construct a
subset B prime which is a subset of
transactions such as the B prime is 0
eyes about which means we can sterilize
the transaction in B prime without
causing any conflict and the size of the
department is maximum among orders all
such subsets the maximal action means we
have least number of our ports now
okay lost its okay one minute
like I say that there is a way to decide
when the prom is survivable and there is
also an algorithm to construct a
sterilization order after we decide this
is Sara as well this is something to do
with the dependency graph and has
something to do with how many cycles or
if there is in a psycho in the
dependency graph so you can look up in a
paper for more details okay so after we
identify this problem we still have the
usual like we know how to decide this is
the so this is a sterilized but now the
question is how it can take the least
number of transaction out of the out of
the dependency graph to make the guapa
cyclic now
there is people have strings study that
and unfortunately and this is mg hard
and apparently we haven't figured out
how to make em T equal to V so we
propose them greedy organisms so that we
can have a design choice or trade-off
between the overhead of the organism and
the performance of the organism
okay so there is some extension where
you can like optimize for different
goals instead of just minimize the
number of ports you can try to phrase my
reduce the tail lit and say or you can
try to power it has some transactions
way so like Amina in dollar value
instead of a like a penny value
transaction so this can also be handled
under the same framework so I guess they
just give you a snip of the performance
numbers we have up to two times the
improvements throughput as well as up to
four times reduction in percentage
presentation 11 so that you don't lose
anything you don't have a trade off here
you actually get pissed off passports in
terms of additional policies we have
like for example we have a college that
try to reduce the very tail light and
see like the three nights four nights
five nights and in this case the new
policy can actually reduce that but up
to six times okay I think I can skip the
conclusion
[Applause]
any questions yes is it single corner or
multi-port this is not equal but but the
recording process has to be like when
you decide the sterilization order so we
have an extension to how to paralyze
different operations and we do like type
like paralyzing we do we do like
horizontal paralyzes you whenever we can
but if we can we do can do pipeline
paralyzation yes how much do you need to
know the read and write sets up front
before you schedule the transaction so
don't know at all
because in this case you also say you
you actually decide the Ceredigion order
after the transaction has finished it is
present so we are trying to decide the
order you already know exactly what are
the Rhydian Rice's yes there is no
approximation oh there is so we can
guarantee it and this is a correct but
we cannot guarantee this is the minimum
okay does it make sense yes but I wonder
why you don't use an approximation if
there are known approach if there if you
can use an approximation then you can
always gather with no really long
approximation because we cannot
sterilize the transaction see if we find
a cycle in a graph you can take this
offline okay thanks
our next speaker is Alec turned off from
Microsoft he's going to talk about
towards learning optimizer for shared
clubs Thanks hello everyone my name is
Alec Jindal and I'm going to talk about
our work on the water learning optimizer
for share clouds this is a joint work
with our awesome intern Chang Gangu and
a whole set of my colleagues here at
Microsoft so we are witnessing a rise of
decatur systems they're really big and
we have so many examples of systems like
hive spark flame calcite and a whole
bunch of offerings even from the
industry and there's a trend towards
making the system's declarative and
having a cost-based optimizer which
essentially says given a user query
it'll automatically figure out the best
physical execution plan for that query
and the way it does is that it estimates
the cardinalities at each point in the
query plan estimate the cost of the plan
and picks the plan with the cheapest
cost so far so good
and of course a good plan leads to good
performance but problem is that the
costs optimizers can make all sorts of
mistakes and the most notorious being
cardinality estimation so much so sure
and so that people believe that it's the
root of all evils
it's a acnes he'll of good optimization
and it's a biggest problem apparently so
it's a really hard problem I would say
so put into basically tune our systems
you know so as to make them really
performant and the things which people
normally do is to think and do things
like you know collect statistics or
provide you know query hints so for
example in sequel server you can you
know add a row count hint or you can
apply some DB administration so there's
also been a rise or in the clouds as
well and what this means for this
systems is that they're being offered as
either managed or even as our less
offerings which means that the end users
now don't have any control and they
can't apply these kinds of tunings any
more so which means they may not they
may not have admin or they not have you
in expertise because it's where long
tail of users who simply show up and
sign up for
any of these big data services and they
don't even actually have control because
it's a managed service so it means the
systems have to self tuned there's no
other option self fielding is a really
hard problem and it's super hard in
these big data systems so but there is
some hope if you look at specific
instances of these systems for instance
if you look at shared cloud
infrastructures what do we mean by that
so if you look at enterprises where
there are sets of people who query or
who like you know process the same sets
of data some sheer data over a shared
infrastructure then they end up actually
producing a massive log of queries on
the same in inputs and that could be
used actually to you know tune the
system so this essentially visible query
log on the same in each search could be
really valuable this might see actually
it turns out that this kind of setting
is actually very typical in enterprise
analytics in fact at Microsoft we have
cosmos which is a shared cloud
infrastructure for doing all of internal
Microsoft analytics and in cosmos we
have a scope query engine that does
batch processing in a job satisfactory
and it has a massive output of hundreds
of thousands of jobs each day which has
been scripted by thousands of users and
they also checks the bytes of data if
you look at the Carnegie estimation in
the scope jobs so we looked at one of
the largest scope customers which is
Asimov and we looked at like one day
what of the locks from them that's how
the estimation looks like so in this
figure the Green Line is the ideal and
even after lots of tuning and constants
and best effort estimation there is a
huge curve of underestimation and
there's a huge overestimation happening
and given that the x-axis is log scale
you can understand that it could be all
over the place basically and it's a hard
problem because scope has this big data
lots of data it's not easy to know
analyze or
statuses on on that data the data is
unstructured and there is lot of custom
user code which ends up being black
boxes but we have some observations here
actually and one thing we observe is
that much of the scope work boards
actually are collecting which means same
sets of queries appear again and again
at some frequency and they also have
lots of shared query sub expressions or
sub graphs so which means that if you
have two queries q1 q2 they may end up
scanning the same items table and
applying the same filter now a question
is how can we leverage this common
sub-expressions or common sub graphs to
build or to learn cardinality models so
of course the easiest thing is that we
can simply cache so if we see a similar
sub expression we can just completely
simply record the value and use it the
next time you see it again the problem
of however is that it's very very has a
very low coverage because the inputs
change we have to change this you know
we can't use a cache anymore and the
feedback has to be online it has to be
materially as soon as we have seen get
applied back immediately which is kind
of tedious the other extreme is ok we
learn models a general model for any sub
graph no saying if you have a single
model for any kind of a sub graph that's
very hard to fit your eyes we tried that
we failed it's hard to train it has a
very high latency when scoring because
we end up having a large a very large
feature vector but most important we had
very low accuracy we could not fit a
single model for all the cases so we
took some middle ground you say okay
let's amongst logical sub expression
parameters and inputs let's only fix
expression and let's allow there are
parameters and inputs to change which
means that we don't learn a single model
no one-size-fits-all let's learn a set
of models which together capture the
entire workload so which means we now
look at sub graph templates which have
the same logical expression but may have
different physical implementations and
different parameters and inputs as an
example suppose we have this join
happening and this is a filter happening
we may have a ply filter
age 18 or age 20 and the inputs may have
changed as well so if he tries this kind
of sub expressions and used a bunch of
features which includes mainly metadata
and parameters and input characteristics
and we tried a bunch of models so we try
it and we found the linear models to be
actually very useful especially the
Poisson regression
it was the most accurate somehow the
figure is not that accurate but it makes
sense because cardinalities can really
the distribution is more exponential so
it can really fall off really and it's
are also non-negative so it makes sense
that it was most accurate if you do all
of that what do we end up basically so
we end up something like this basically
so we see wherever we have models if
they are super accurate basically you
know we can actually very close to the
ideal almost this is actually scary hey
like how how actually can be and if you
look at the default of course we have
orders of magnitude more accurate
because we look at we optimize for
specific instance that for this customer
can be done the cardinality models but
the other question is what's about
applicability are these mods applicable
to the entire worker or not so we looked
at the applicability what percentage of
sub graphs we have models for turns out
that we approximately have after 2 days
of training approximately 65% of the sub
graphs have models and we need to train
around once a month because after a
month we lose some applicability so we
have to train up approximately once a
month so as to make sure that we cover
those 65% that's very enough if you look
at the end-to-end feedback loop how does
how does this whole thing work so when
we have this our scope engine which has
the compiler optimizer scheduler and
runtime and we take all the logs you
know we train them offline and
periodically and we end up with a large
number of very small models which
super accurate and then we feed it back
to a feedback service which provides
these models as hints to future queries
so the queries can choose to use or
choose to ignore it's up to them it's a
hint additional hint for every query in
the future and then the optimizer uses
the models to feature eyes and because
they're small it's easy to future eyes
so we have no scooting overhead and they
are accurate and one important thing is
that once if some query fails or if
somebody has to go and debug then they
can actually also understand the weights
what features have no which way it's
because there are simple linear models
so each of these actually were a
requirements we had in the scope
environments so we were able to achieve
them and if you do all of that how does
the end-to-end performance look like so
we looked at some of some sort of
queries from Asimov we really ran them
with the default and the new basically
optimizer and if you look at latency
well sometimes there is sometimes
there's not improvements but if you look
at the total processing time we found
interestingly that there were
significant improvements and the reason
that happened was because we were
actually scheduling a lot less number of
vertices or containers because we were
in the overestimation which was so so
heavy so by avoiding that we actually
save resources because give this kind of
queries which is important for this kind
of in fact no infrastructures medes
which is pay as you go
we also have looked at the problem of
learning bias because the only learn
based on what we have album observed and
we meant up basically no having a bias
so we look at how we can you know try
out alternate orders of joints and
maximize observation so that we can
train on those new observations has been
more details of this are in the paper
which we have so feel free to have a
look at that but in summary and the
takeaways we had in our work was as
follows
big data systems are increasingly cost
based you know optimized
there's no like user on manual tuning
they have to be self tuned in fact users
cannot even tune the systems anymore
within their managed in server less it's
very hard to achieve a one-size-fits-all
optimize another system we cannot really
optimize system for all instances and
scenarios because the clouds and the
workloads are so diverse it's very hard
but there is hope if you look at
specific instances for example a given
shared infrastructure then we can do
something there
we saw very promising results on the
scope workloads you can achieve high
accuracy and large applicability and we
could actually produce significantly the
resource requirements and this is just a
starting point we believe that the
learning cognitive models of step
towards making a self-learning
optimizers and systems and we are
working more towards that thank you
[Applause]
question how large were your mother is
how many choices model what is the
maximum number of choices a mother
sweeping right so even in terms of each
model we had was laissez like a simple
linear model like so because Lana model
at any sub-expression basically so we
and we were looking at like the places
where we had the maximum bang for the
buck which means that we can really see
them a large number of times so it does
not matter how many number of joints we
have that think about is how many like
features or how many parameters we have
and interestingly we had most parameters
where we had you do is the user-defined
code basically so wherever they appeared
we had very very large number of
parameters and that really make sure
that we he tries them otherwise things
can go horribly wrong so dress was our
main challenge do you think this will be
also sorry again for welding systems
reading this will also make it to get
back like is although the right so we
are engaging with some toasted cassava
folks and seeing if you can apply there
as well
there would be some changes probably how
we apply feedback and how much you go
ahead you can always
so there are some concerns but we are
engaging industries we don't have answer
yet they engage with them and see how we
can apply it there has been thanks and
we'd like next to a mere from guru who
is going to talk about machine learning
in Google machine learning in bakui I've
been in the Vickery team for for four
years I've been at Google for six before
that I was at MSR before that I was a
Michigan so it's good to be back here
I'm gonna give a very short overview of
equity and motion laser is gonna give
you a better overview probably and then
I talk about why we decided to do
bigquery ml ml and briefly touch and
touch on syntax and then talk about our
solution to one of the simpler ml
algorithms that we support linear
regressions we have two solutions I'm
going to go through why we decided to do
each one and finally we have time you
can do questions so bigquery for those
of you who don't know B query goopy
queries Google's cloud base sequel data
warehouse as a service for mostly
analytics
you can use it right now for free it has
a free tier so you can try it basically
it's an enterprise data warehouse it's a
fully managed service within sequel with
a sequel API it can scale to petabytes
of storage and support encryption
streaming and all the nice features that
you will you want from your data
warehouse so the quarry ml one of the
things that we saw from enterprise
customers and that use bigquery is that
the sequel analysts that they have their
main job is to extract inside
from beta and usually it's based on some
historic data that they stored they want
to extract something based on the
history or they want to predict
something in the future and you can see
two queries here that these are just
simple queries the first one is trying
to come up with the average income based
on state and the second one is top
orders of top and orders of customers so
our goal here was to expand the the
sequel language to give analysts the
tools based on math concepts statistical
methods ml algorithms to do this insight
extraction without needing to learn
anything new
without needing to learn Python or
tensorflow scikit-learn without needing
to move their data in and out just
staying where they're comfortable and a
video with even minimal need to learn
machine learning so that's the first
school that I've I list here it's you
know democratizing ml for business
customers without leaving the seco
environment the second thing that we
wanted to do was analyze being able to
analyze large data sets without sampling
them obviously you can always sample
your data say take it into your local
machine or one node of your database for
some problems that's suitable for some
problems that is not suitable so our
goal was to use the power of bigquery to
scale to petabytes of data for ML
algorithms and as I said we don't want
to have this move data out move to do to
do the machine learning and then are
there somehow bring that model back into
the database or move more data out to
use that in in in that model for system
that's ingesting data all the time and
these models need to be retrained
sometimes daily that's a that's an
expensive pipeline and it's beyond what
the sequel analysts
can do there are examples of this effort
before to introduce ml into database
obviously they're not the first people
who are doing this at least on the
syntax side I have two samples here from
systems that are out there the first one
is heavily based on R and Python
it-it-it to me it's a non descriptive
syntax that you know if you know are
probably you understand the red part if
you know sequel you know the rest but
mixing the two for someone who know
who's a psychoanalyst doesn't really
make make a lot of sense the second one
is a little bit better
this shows how they do generalized
linear models one type of machine
learning model in sequel
there are there are a few issues with
that system or own name the system but
there are a few issues one is if you go
through different models you see
completely different syntax sometimes
there is tvf somehow sometimes there's
UDF sometimes there is UDA the way that
the model is applied to the data
sometimes is a join sometimes there's
some other special syntax so every model
is different so there's no unique syntax
or there is no common syntax for
training and print prediction so what we
decided to do was to extend C code EDL's
and the same way that create table is
the standard form of creating tables we
introduced create model and you just
basically pass your model name there is
a set of options which are really
optional and those can control your ml
algorithm if you want the knobs to tune
some stuff and then you pass your data
in the add statement so the same running
example that we had for the income based
on census data here you can see a model
that we can create in in bigquery a
linear regression model that predicts
the income based on the input data and
you can in fact change the model type to
something else if if you want to try
different things you can add a very
close to the select statement
to predict on a specific you know time
time range or group by state or whatever
you want the create model statement
stays the same and then to apply
prediction we have one tvf for
prediction across all models so you pass
your model name and then you tell pass
your data so here you can see how
prediction can be done for the same
model that we we trained you just put
the inputs where state and job and here
you just you know just pass pass those
in we do have a bunch of other T vs for
other interactions that you want to do
with your models for example if you want
to evaluate the model based on and get
some metrics like how good this model is
we have another tvf but all of these CVS
are same syntax we pass the model and in
pass your data so the model is basically
here is it is a top-level object in the
catalog of the database on and you can
store it however you want you can have
it as a table or as you know set up
binary blobs that's up to a specific
database so that's the syntax and we
believe this syntax improves the
usability of ml for psychoanalysts
compared to the current workflows which
is either based on moving data using
python and r or using notebooks and you
know sample your data in memory of the
notebook environment so moving forward
i'm going to talk about two approaches
for for the same running example that we
had so predicting income based on census
data the first one i'm going to go over
a very common approach called iterative
gradient descent so let's look at the
problem first just quickly so what we
want to solve is basically find a set of
weights that we can apply to the
features of our input data features
where state their job and
State so we want to have we want to find
weights for those and the training data
is modeled as X here rows are training
examples columns are features so we have
two columns in which are state and and
and job title and then the observations
are the income that we want to predict
so we want to find w-4 based on our
training data and the the common way to
do this is to iteratively minimize this
objective function the first part is a
loss which basically says how far we are
from the values that we want to predict
and the two other terms are
regularization terms to control
overfitting of the model so that's what
we want to solve and what we decided to
do was to basically given that our data
size input could be petabytes we wanna
use the power of the database so we want
to use sequel to solve these equations
and we decided to basically do the
gradient descent in pure sequel there is
no extra function or any modification to
the database that we made for solving
these these these equations so we
represent our data as a table our model
although is an object in the backend we
store it as a table and we basically run
a set of queries for each iteration of
gradient descent and so there's a paper
from 12 my colleagues that you can you
can look about you can look up about the
details of all of these queries and all
the techniques they use to optimize it
basically each iteration is as I said
our sequel statements and there are a
bunch of techniques to hide the
complexity and and make the query scale
I'm not going to go into the detail you
can you can look them up or you can talk
to me after talk the second approach is
closed form solution so if the data is
not petabytes and lots of customers may
have smaller data the data set now we
still want to be able to train but there
there could be a closed-form solution
that doesn't need all of the nodes of
the database - - to solve it here again
we have the same same equation and it
just doesn't note that the training data
usually is an M by n matrix and M which
is the number of examples is usually
much much larger than n which is the
number of features so the closed form
solution usually just uses linear
algebra to to solve this and the
solution for W so I wrote it here it's
it's a it's a well-known solution I'm
not going to go into the detail of how
we got it this is you can look it up on
Wikipedia it basically consists of a
bunch of a few multiplications and a
matrix inversion and these are both hard
things to do in a database
especially the inversion so the way we
go about this is we do the matrix
multiplication using joins in Vickery
because b kotov does pretty well for for
for scaling joints and the matrix
inversion is basically the first term
that you see X 3 X that's an N by n
matrix and remember that M was much
bigger than n and n is the number of
features so it's a pretty small matrix
you don't you're not gonna have more
than thousand features or 10,000
features so we can fit that in memory so
we basically run a query to do the
multiplications matrix we put them in a
table as like row row number column
number the value and the the
multiplications our joins and the matrix
inversion because it fits in memory of
one chart we do use a fast solver off
the shelf to do the matrix inversion
finally how do we decide between the two
as I said a psychoanalysts in care about
any of these they just want to say
select star from T train on this so all
of these are handled by us so we decide
if the data fits in the memory by Luke
get the number of training features if
you have more than 10,000 features we
know that that matrix is too big we are
not gonna matrix do matrix inversion if
there is overfitting issues so close
form is not great because it doesn't
support edwin regularization if we see
that number of training examples is not
enough and we are gonna get into
overfitting issues we go back to the
gradient descent and if if they're
explicit options for elbow
regularization or warm start we go to
gradient descent and finally otherwise
we use normal equation and conclusion
basically as I said I'm going to repeat
the same stuff this is meant for
psychoanalysts not ml experts and our
goal is to enable this purely in sequel
I get some out of time and thanks to the
bigquery team
[Applause]
it depends on on on your data size so to
give you an example in a sequel query if
you do a group I and a sum on 10 rows
I'm in any database I'm pretty sure if
you take that on your local machine it
would be much much faster but if you
scale that to a billion rows then it
would be different so it depends on if
your data is really small or if the data
is big so if you have a billion rows you
can knowledge on tensorflow
that's how was that not on a single
machine if your data doesn't fit in
memory oh you have cancer
if if everything fits in the memory of a
single machine is going to be faster
than Bitcoin in our just for this for
pretty much any query yes right so my
question is training has this pattern of
making multiple passes over the data and
you are burning SQL queries in every
pass versus exporting the data one time
and running in a customized ml system
with hardware acceleration so how does
the performance compare especially when
your datasets grow for one thing that we
didn't touch here is for doing any
training
maybe training is so training is one
step I would say is 10 percent 20
percent of the complexity of what you
want to do there's an 80 percent that
you want to prove process and every time
you through process and you want to
train and see okay did my pre-processing
work you have to export your data train
your model show up more data into the
model and say okay my something went
wrong let me go back get another slice
of the data exported train again see it
works or not so it's an iterative
process it's is not it's not just one
one shot I train and ok I'm done you're
right that the training per se may be
faster if you give it enough resources
but training is just one step the data
in the same environment that you know
how to protect data either an ml expert
you don't know so the problem is that
the psycho analyst knows how to prep the
data the person who does the machine
learning doesn't necessarily know or is
not in the database time bar but it's
not the same person who pushes
I agree I should buy that you know are
the same radius to do everything exactly
requested said I remember in two
American Sycamore there's a one paper
from College of London is about actually
heat cleanser cleanser because you can
be the Vantage of hobbies Asaka
expression for the symmetric
yes approve that's the the matrix
calculation is the subset of proof I
actually can be used the result is
actually a faster the tensor flow I
think we get the pepper dip but that my
my my my friends at the first questions
that can compare thank reproduce at the
result on a paper and Steve actually
work on the car I don't have
head-to-head comparison I guess they do
to take advantage that that something
special to my vision for the use the
Superferry to do the Dibble metrics one
of you take a bunch of the questions
offense Lorna sorry as well great so our
last speaker before the break is Mona
from Google and he's going to talk about
big great analytics storage and then
afterwards again we have a break short
break let's get food come in here again
to talks and an arm and okay so my name
is Masha poo Szymanski but this stock
was supposed to be done by another
person Pavan she couldn't get here
because of the snow so he asked me to do
it I saw those slides first time in my
life couple of hours ago so I'll have to
improvise a little bit
let's see what they say so
yeah so I walk in Google and be creative
for seven years before that there was a
Microsoft work on cosmos and scope
capita sheet still alive and before that
in sickle cell so be clear I made a
describe it beautifully is this fully
managed it's yellow
it was Cheryl s before there was a war
shareware less you know it's data was
housed in the cloud so in this talk I
will try to focus on on the storage part
and not talk about execution or runtime
I just distributed parts of it and so on
so some of the things that big Larry
does is wait additional data warehouse
link right so it supports you know and
starting snowflake schemas and doing
joints and GML and all the classic stuff
but probably it will be a little bit
more interesting to see what makes it
special so when the scale now I welcome
Google everything which is less than
exabyte you know people think you're not
shears so it is it is exabyte multiple
exabytes of storage and petabytes of
queries another thing that makes it kind
of interesting and unique is that it is
one big system which kind of there are
no database instances so for example we
have you know hundreds of public
datasets a ton of stock prices weather
patterns what have you you can
immediately join it with your data all
the data is available as if it was in
your own instance so another interesting
thing is that even though have most of
the features of the classic data
warehouse we also have a lot of features
to support data storage for the you know
applications more modern applications
not done by the Kimball box right and
some interesting characteristics of
those you know people don't design they
like they spoil but this no sequel right
they say why don't we put some semi
structured data in an hour
used to be XML fuchsia gonads JSON and
when I figure out what happens later
that is generalized there are no joints
it's also very popular in the smaller
and applications kind of to have this
team you know somebody said SCAF core or
something like that just say you know
let's write all the data and you know
steam it in and we'll figure out later
what to do so bigquery has very very
good solutions to all of those and it
does them in principle database way
right not eventual consistency like real
stuff so let's directly should go one by
one and talk about few of those so at
the data layout layer so this column
where sessions to data warehouse it's
column based system but with the twist
that it has to deal with shame structure
data again somebody before said you know
we use nested data so it's not
relational well of course nested data is
relational since equal 2011 which
introduced erase and moon cassettes and
aircraft and so on
so because the latest image structure
doesn't mean it doesn't have schema it
has will have some interesting ways of
how to deal with it and how to provide
efficient storage and execution on top
of it now for some of the other things
there I guess now become very standard
in column based data bases you know many
different and columns what can you do
you know statistics and bloom filters
and things like that
execution push to the compressed data so
you can execute some things like
predicates and simple computes without
even decompression kill data row the
ordering you know relations don't have
the orders of we're free to change the
order of the roles not necessarily
served by one of the columns but just
try to optimize some of the metrics for
example you know tank to put similar
values closer together you can get
better
early early runs and things like that so
so all those happens
for the day clout and by the way we have
not a paper but we have Freight up which
goes into more depth about some of those
issues so now if we go to the very
global level so I said you know global
managed database it's actually a more
like a journal database so the wave of
aqua storage so each zone right the
query has separation of storage and
compute and storage is on distributed
file system so this already gives fault
tolerance but in say tej involves so
immediately replicate that into three
zones and there is also off engine
application so I guess we store data so
many times it daily must be a fault all
around so now what happens within the
zone so one of the things that we do is
the way we start again remember we're
the MotoGP
data warehouse so the way metadata about
table is structured we work with you
know split table beta chunks which a
mutable right so every time and to
commit them to the metadata storage so
every time there is any type of change
there is a new immutable block and I
will go into a little bit more detail
about it and you know you can say you
waste a lot of storage but hey Google
will have so much storage who don't know
what to do with that but having data
immutable makes a lot of things a lot a
lot simpler right whether it's been
caching or for example there was talk
about this you know how you apply
courage analogous tomates if we thought
originally estimates were good idea
which we don't them cause based
optimization in general you know we
could have computed them on those
immutable chunks and remember for the
next execution so again this simplifies
our story a lot so let's go through
throw one example what you know how to
manage this immutable chance since we're
fully managed service without everything
for the user
okay so here's one example
of up to my sister's suppose there was
think I mean sat in the firm time so all
the three chunks their pens
okay simplest possible case you know at
some later time system on its own
resources schism doesn't even know about
it goes in so came I don't you combine
them together so one megabyte hundred
kilobytes and two megabytes together
give us two point five megabytes because
maybe it compares beta which was
different and coding core whatnot so
from that point on I guess it's from
another slide but from that point on
right it's exactly same data here in
this chunk or in this one so you know
you can vary either one and we'll
probably create this one unless we do
time travel and let's talk about time
travel to bit later so this kind of
stoic optimization with a lot of it but
it's on individual block layer you know
we can reorder columns if we notice that
decorate together we put them close to
each other where the rolls we pick the
best encoding credits
it's Salamone replicated and like a lot
lot of things so earlier if our p.m. so
here they would have wanted me to say we
use a male to do this because we have to
assemble for everything but we use
algorithms to do this
but we do take into account you know
historic great patterns and you know how
this data is actually used I guess I
should say to the mouse okay
time tell since everything is immutable
we get this really nice feature for free
I saw in sequel it is the closed for
system time as off you can go back in
time you can see how a table looked in
the past you can look you know show me
the data that was added in the last 30
minutes it's another time of form of
time travel so it works kind of with
immutable data pretty simple so let's
say were appended to chunks and then
starship to miser okay that another one
so now if you want to see how data
looked after g2 you can just steal it
from here because contains the same data
but if you want to see how they two
looked between Chi 1 and Chi 2 you go to
the older one okay and so on so this is
kind of almost side effect because of
the story he texture which shows now
what happens when you have GML so said
you know vana told cheap eva lesap to
mice to you know update single hall
it's more like update older us with same
condition so again what we would do here
is we will write a new chunk I try not
allowed to do they write existing clan
but when we do that the kind of remember
so let's say the updated customer I want
to say four so updates a model test
delete plus a pent-up and say oh so long
we need to care about Julius right so
the metadata and transaction manager and
particular knows which data came from
whether those errors so it we don't they
write all the data when you update a
little bit of it but we have those kind
of pointers we remember which data
actually belongs to which chunk okay so
again they immutable they can even share
the same you know also snapshot the same
data
and everything folks time travel works
with it and all other features works
with it so last thing that I want to
talk because I think it's kind of really
cool and unique is the stamen congestion
that we'll have in big crater so as I
mentioned in the beginning is it is very
popular with kind of wave of modern
applications kind of to say okay
everything that we have you know all the
events that we have just open a firehose
and write them and we'll figure out
later what to do
maybe we can analyze them in place maybe
we can do a little bit of yield XI and
transform them
but first let's steam everything so
again because we're database we'll have
to have you know good guarantees about
it so steaming injection has to be as
reliable and and have all the same
characteristics as if you were App
Engine data let's say with batch or with
GML commands so we'll have special sub
she no I don't finish here so have
dedicated subsystem to deal with
streaming so what it has to do so the
way it works it is you know HTTP
endpoint where you can send your data
and the moment you got the arc the data
is committed so what we do inside is we
write this data first in the
optimized format because it's the
fastest right okay and since we're
talking about big big fire hose we need
to write three really fast and what
really works fine for us is if you write
only a little bit of data then one
doesn't matter what we do performance is
going to be good no matter what and if
you are writing a lot of data it gives
great opportunity to do basic right so
also because one system which works like
they're not database instances we can
multiplex
data from different tables together and
bash it together and latex figure out
which data belongs to whom also do a lot
of load balancing so
if you start writing a lot become to
single table but I magically can shout
it even across different zones and take
and sell it all together so it's all
consistent there is a special form of
the stewardship to miser which kind of
looks at all this right optimize data
and decides what to do with it
part of it will stay in memory because
you know it's the data that you're at
most recently has the highest chance of
being cleared right you want to know
like let's say your instrumentation kV
upset you want to know what's going on
right now not what was two or three
minutes ago so part of it stays in
memory in memory optimized thermit part
of it when there is enough gets
converted to the coulomb optimized
format and so on so I guess a lot of
time now there are many other
interesting features but I guess the
most interesting oh that would be a
subject for Shepard talk but basically
the problem of cost based optimization
is it's very unstable something little
chip it's like am i right something
changes and your plan changes and nobody
knows why right so we have other
mechanisms which are better than cause
based estimation like adaptive
optimization and things like that which
are much more stable and and also
walkabout like and you don't pay big
price for the mistake because they can
self correct themselves all the way as
the CAG Claire goes on a little bit more
complex than that but the idea is as the
Cray Pigasus it corrects itself on the
fly now it is what did it see so far
what should I do next so just a pendant
but that only applies for other style
queries
hold up style queries or long brain
queries right what does old spell pose
Rosina cute well it applies to all the
Claire's well I guess we're datavac
house over on your other types of
Claire's okay and one more than yours
self-join or different times yes you can
yeah I mean as far as far as query
optimizer is concerned it will see two
different able metadata system we'll
figure out where data for each one
everything cool off yeah all right let's
thank the speaker again
[Applause]